well an Alabama mother who says bullying
led to our daughter's suicide blamed her
school for not doing enough to protect
the child nine year old Mackenzie Adams
took her own life last week her mother
says the fourth grader was the target of
constant racial taunts and name-calling
DeMarco Morgan is outside the school in
Demopolis Alabama he spoke with
Mackenzie's mother
DeMarco this is such a sad story good
morning good morning
Jasmine Adam says she enrolled her
daughter here hoping to get a fresh
start because the little girl had been
bullied at another school but the
taunting continued so she alerted school
officials but according to police school
officials say they knew nothing about
the bullying only adding to the mother's
heartbreak my baby she was happy she was
joyful she walk in the room just her
eyes just brightens up a room Jasmine
Adam says after a daughter Mackenzie
started fourth grade at us Jones
elementary school the nine year old
started complaining about problems with
her classmates what kind of problems
there were children picking on her I
think a lot of it standing from she
wrote to and from school with a little
white boy it was like our best friend
the mother says one boy would write
Mackenzie notes in class I know one
particular time he called her n-word and
a B word Jasmine says she voiced her
concerns to school officials who she
says reassured her they would keep an
eye on her daughter but on the morning
of December 3rd Mackenzie took her own
life in her family's home the results of
a police investigation are still pending
but so far police say they have found no
evidence the school knew of the bullying
the Demopoulos city school system
offered its condolences to the family
but says its own internal investigation
concluded there have been no findings of
any reports of bullying by either the
student or family so you're saying the
school's claims that they knew nothing
about this a bogus yeah they are I don't
know why they would say they knew
nothing about it but they did
Mackenzie's death is part of a sobering
trend in the US while the causes are
unclear the suicide rate for children
ages 5 to 14 has almost tripled since
2007 Jasmine Adams is employing school
officials to steal
to bullying by their students you have
my child I was a day so that means that
we have to trust you to do the right
thing when it comes to the safety of my
child
they didn't do it they didn't do it and
it hurts
let's say there are signs to be on the
lookout for when it comes to your child
being bullied look for unwillingness to
want to go to school
falling grades and also sleepless nights
as for Mackenzie's funeral it's set for
Saturday here at our school at 11 a.m. I
understand that mother's pain it does
hurt and I hope this brings some
awareness again a reminder to people
about the effects of bullying I keep
sinking nor at fourth grade 9 years old
how you even think that that's even an
option or you even know how to do that
to take your own life you really feel
for her mother at this time how much
pain she was in exactly